tradition at all it's about rules and
regulations I like history I like
certain traditions I'd like certain
rituals but as soon as they're encased
in rules and regulations they become
inclusive I mean you look at like Jesus
saying okay all you have to do basically
people is love one another and
everything will build on that but then
you have everyone coming after him that
says okay you have to love one another
and here's these 40 other rules and then
these rules and these rules and you and
you know you have to then be this aspect
you know you can't be Protestant and and
or you can't be Catholic or you can't be
a just nondenomination as long as you
pray and love you have to be in this
religion you have to wear these clothes
you have to do it's all the rules and
regulations that comes with anything
with going to school with everything we
do even movements great movements
important movements that make change
they get like eventually like clubs and
then all they care about is their
special interest and I think it's the
rules
these rules and regulations that
constantly were fighting and trying to
shed and if that makes the same you know
less moral and my less moral because I
refuse to have an organized religion I
don't feel that at all because I feel
completely unfettered my relationship
with God is unfettered by a bunch of
rules and regulations about how to get
to him and I think that you know is the
real key is just to be a good person
you're just a good person you know I
don't care what side of the
you-know-what you know everybody can
keep their values keep their traditions
but you know as Lennie said live in
harmony you know you
I don't think that all arts should talk
to everybody
Robert Mapplethorpe didn't feel like his
x-rated photographs or his his
sadomasochistic photographs were for
everyone they weren't for his mother
they weren't for you know young people
what her children they were for specific
people a lot of people they look at a
Jackson Pollock it makes them ill but
they will love a Vermeer you know I
don't think that everything has to be
for everybody
some people might never like Allen
Ginsberg's poems that's okay they'll
like maybe Wordsworth you know we have a
whole spectrum and a whole you know all
of the possibilities to to enter the
creative sphere and and defined you know
where we relate to this you know
expansive consciousness and it could be
through you know Whistler or it could be
you know through vogner and it's just
you know I think that you know it's it
doesn't have to just be through
something new or something you know I
don't like all new art in fact I can't
stand most contemporary art you can take
all of Jeff Koons and throw them into I
don't even know you could like burry him
into the the you know some crater or
something put them in the Hawaiian
crater it's called the shlok of the news
I'm just saying that mm-hmm it's it's
just for those like Jesus said those who
will hear will hear and those who will
see will see I would have been very
happy though we were never in the
mainstream even when we had one
successful song it was on such a
controversial album that you know we
managed always to stay like lake in the
illuminated underground I would have
loved if we could have written a song on
horses that I used to call it my dream
of writing the hit of the world writing
a song that everybody heard and was like
felt uplifted by it everybody it was
like you know the per
before top song you know reach out for
me or something to write one like that
but I don't have that gift you know it's
a gift that the you know Smokey Robinson
had or various people have but I don't
have that particular gift and I don't
say that like being humble it's just a
truth I mean if I had it I'd with would
have written the head of the world I
don't think it's important to stay in
the underground to be an artist I I
would love to see the greatest artists
that ever lived suddenly beloved by the
whole world you know but so you know you
just we just keep doing our work you
know it's like we never cared whether we
were even though I had that secret dream
we didn't do our work to you know make
money or to to be pop stars or dress in
a certain way we got in trouble at least
once a week everything that we were
asked to do we usually did the opposite
not to be contrary just because that's
the way we were going we were like no
I'm not going to brush my hair for the
cover of horses I'm not going to like no
I'm not going to wear a dress on the
cover of this album no I'm not going to
you know take the word pissing out of
pissing in the river always always on no
I'm not going to call it you know rock
and roll potato instead of rock and roll
[ __ ] I'm gonna you know no I'm not
going to shave my armpits I mean it was
like stupidest fights every single
everything we did was the fight right
but we were like we were happy to fight
I mean Jesus Christ you know to be a as
a as a young person I knew if you're
gonna be a poet or an artist or anything
like this a a troubadour you were gonna
suffer you're probably going to be poor
you were gonna maybe have TB I mean
anything that's going to happen but you
were going to you know be blessed with
the opportunity to create in this manner
and unfettered by you know the world's
expectations and demands you were just
going to do your work and and that's
what we did and I would have to say that
that is a legacy
that we got from the counterculture of
the 1960s the sense of idealism the
sense of possibility that you could
choose your own path and if it was rocky
well that's you know that's Rolly I mean